hello everyone and welcome back to the
grand chester it's the tata steel rapid
event in india it's magnus carlsen
versus Bingley rain is the final round
of the rapid so this is around 9:00 and
it's really really an impressive game
for those of you who maybe don't know
the venue of where the players are
playing the tournament is the National
Library in India here we have a very
nice photo of of the audience so you can
see that it's it's quite crowded much
more people than than in other
tournaments so if any of you are in the
audience and watching this video do
comment in the description below would
we would be very awesome
so that being said let's check out the
game as the title suggests sanu poison
in to bring into the the marshal attack
always an interesting idea so it's a
very theoretical struggle we're not
gonna dwell too long on the opening we
have E 4 E 5 9 f3 Knight to c6 and now
Bishop to b5 going for the rule opus
with a 6 more fees defense rush up to a4
and Knight to f6
we have castles and Bishop the e7 and
although I've seen ding played the
Marshall attack quite a lot well not a
lot but I've seen him play it but I
don't think I've ever seen
Magnus playing against the Marshall so
rook to e1 and b5 I'm not saying that he
never played against the mark I'm just
saying I've never seen it
Bishop to b3 we have castles and c3 here
Magnus invites ding to go for the
Marshall attack and we have d5 the
Marshall attack is on the board he
captures Knight captures and of course
Knight captures on e5 Knight captures
rook captures and here even though in
the old days you could you could you
could have gone Knight of 6 Bishop to b7
there are some other moves that we're
played today in modern day chess you
will most likely see c6 this is what
ding goes for with d3 by magnitude e4 is
the most popular line b3 now is what
Magnus prefers here Bishop to d6
rook back to e 1 and now Bishop to f5
just developing and the bishop nicely
Queen to f3 the attacking the bishop and
now Queen to h4 we had this position
many times as we always enjoy covering
the marshal attack so here we already
mentioned but in case um we don't know
if you capture the bishop Queen captures
King f1 and rook 88 will give white a
lot of problems since squint h1 will be
made so you have to play something real
capture screen each one check King goes
back a check and now you're gonna block
with the bishop but even though your
upper piece you have a king I need to
and it's it's a very important position
to play it's unclear how you will
develop the knight you can't do it for
the moment as the rope would hang and
it's although it may be possible to play
it and no one no one actually plays it
since why would you yeah so after Queen
to h4 with g3 pushing the Queen back and
now Queen h3 guarding the bishop from
there and now Bishop to e3
we have Bishop captures on d3 and now
again this position has been reached
quite quite a few times 9th to d2 is the
main idea here but here across and just
goes for Bishop captures on d5 he just
grabs the pawn and Bishop captures on d5
is a new move in the position at least
in in top tier tournaments so as I move
17 we have a completely new game and ok
Dean captures the bishop and we have
Queen captures on d5 so here Carlsen
doesn't mind grabbing grabbing a pawn
and also both of the bishops are under
attack so how can how can ding avoid
such a such a loss rook a to d8 now
saying okay you can capture my bishop
but if Queen captures on d3 then of
course the Bishop captures and g3 just
finishes the game now the Queen is under
attack
the Queen th2 is coming and there is no
good reply to this after with the Queen
moves you're gonna go Bishop captures an
H - now we have to go to h1 King each
one there should be eight or or wherever
doesn't really matter
King Jiwon and now rook the d6 will now
end the game so you know well it is
possible to play this I'm sure all of
the all of the top grandmasters and
maybe even not stop grandmasters know
how to end it this game with black if
such a position happens so ok you could
block with rook if Bishop therefore now
Ruby g6
can be met with Bishop to g3 but it does
help youjust Bishop captures and you're
just falling apart that captures rook
captures king of two Queen checks you
have to go back in if one and rho b g1
is made so although something like this
will never happen it's good to know so
dink play the rook a to the 8th I
believe without much hesitation Queen to
g2 now going back with the Queen and now
Quinta CA now let's cross and grab the
pawn he's interested in a Queen's right
he wants to trade down and enjoy his
extra pounding of course says not
interested I have to bash a pair I'm
gonna push h5h for create an attack
against your king Knight the d2 by
Magnus now continuing development and
Bush back to f5 now with ideas of
kicking the Queen away from there with
Bishop h3 with Bishop the d4 by Magnus
now not allowing the roof to have the D
file for himself and also in the future
this might be an issue for black rook f
e8 here ding prepares to tuck the bishop
back in for later and f3 now with the
ship the f8 will be a nice defender and
later if you need it you can always just
bring it out and now a3 by Magnus
we've looked east 6 preparing to double
up on the D on the e-file and here
Magnus trades once we have rook actress
and Queen captures on e6 Queen to f2 now
preparing to bring the rook into the
game with rook to e1 but of course rook
to e8 ding doesn't allow it
and now Knights to f1 preparing Knights
to e3 and here if you try Queen e2 White
was to play Knight e3 and force you into
a queen trade where you just have a well
White has a perfectly fine position and
he's still up a pawn so we don't really
have the option of something like this
so dink continues with h5 he wants to
push h4 and open up the defense is in in
front of course and skiing with Knights
- III attacking the bishop and the
bishop to h3 now rook to e1
now preparing to trade trade off the
rooks with Knights the c2 so Queen to c6
getting the Queen out of the way and now
Knight the g2 again offering a rook
trade we look at force anyone better to
trade rooks then leave Magnus with the
open e file we have Knight captures
anyone and now
Queen to g6 but now Carson is able to
trade down even further even further
basically only compensation dink has is
the bishop repair and if it's not
utilized well it's not really
compensation so here Queen to c2 Magnus
offers a queen trade ding of course
declines it Bishop to a5 and now Queen
to d2 with Bishop back the e6 and now
Queen to d3 again offering a queen trade
ding again declines and the Queen to e3
slowly but surely Magnus improving the
position of his Queen Bishop back the
ECX and now Bishop to c5 now offering a
trade of dark square Bishop ding except
with the ship characters Queen captures
and now Queen to be one attacking the
knight anyone also the pawn on v2 so
Queen to f2 only will move that prevents
both threats and now Bishop to b5 okay
with into g2 now on pinning the knight
can once again enter the game and a5 now
here
ding wants to push b4 with Queen to e2
now with with ideas of delivering some
checks along the back rank so Queen to
f5 bringing the Queen back into the game
now the f3 pawn will be will be
threatened also Bishop to e6 and queen
Thierry might be an idea in the future
but okay for the moment the f3 pawn is
nicely protected King f2 unpinning now
you might even push f4 at some point if
needed
and the Bishop to e6 now with night the
c2 now preparing Knights to d4 a nice
dark Square and a nice central square
four crossings Knight and the Queen to
h3 now threatening Queen characters here
King the g1 defending in the now Bishop
to c4 so excellent squares for four
dings pieces with Quinta eh check King
to h7 and now you have to prevent Queen
to f1 mate and if you try it with Queen
to e1
it's a very slow thing just continues
with the attack with h4 so here cross
and finds Knights to e3 attacking the
bishop also guarding f1 so it's not a
problem
ding goes back Queen to e6 and now comes
Queen captures on e6 h 4 is too slow
here if h4 just Queen Queen check and
you
pick up the pawn so it's not a problem
even though you'd have a dub sorry after
the key moves like cking JT would trade
here and you would have a doubled point
here but still you're up two points so
shouldn't be a problem after ninety
three we have Queen to e6 well first
this Queen on e6 obviously and now
across and just straight with Queen
captures Bishop captures preserving the
bishop against night and now Magnus
doesn't want to allow a force of b4 well
he doesn't mind a for now he just
doesn't want to allow it before pushing
before as you will never be able to put
b4 again we have a capture Sun before
eight characters and now g5 by ding and
again h4 creating more weaknesses for
ding we have G captures on h4 and now G
captures on h4 we have King to g6 ding
starts bringing the King into the game
and now King f2 King to f6 now comes
Knight f1 preparing Knight the g3 to go
after the h5 point and here
ding tries a very interesting idea he
tries to trap crossings night he plays
King e5 Knight the g3 and now f5 he
offers the h5 pawn we have Knight
captures on h5 Magnus calculate
precisely that it might well it is
possible to capture the pawn or maybe it
isn't we'll see what happens ding pushes
f4 and now it's very dangerous then not
the g3 square has been taken from the
night and if you try something weird
let's say king e2 then you just get
Bishop f7 attacking the knight Knight d7
and King of 6 and the knight is trapped
no squares are available to the night as
they are covered by the King and by the
bishop so here
Magnus goes Knight to g7 it's the only
good move here we have brush-up to f7
grabbing the h5 square away from the
knight a preparing King to f6 the travel
but now we have h5 King to f6 and now h6
defending the knight with King to g6 and
now what Carson found when he decided to
go after the H point night the h5 that's
the whole point because now if you
capture it h7 just Queens there's no
stopping the pawn
so here at being saw that he he he
cannot allow this he played King
captures on h6 but now comes Knight
captures on f4 and here ding was very
sad obviously but then again he he did
beat Magnus in in the tiebreaks of the
single Cup so good for Magnus to get his
revenge but I don't think the ding was
hoping to go down while he plays the
Marshall attack and here we even have a
photo of this position
courtesy of Leonard Otis official
photographer of the Grantchester there
you have it and that's the position on
the board King goes to g5 now you can
see that ding is not very happy with
himself also Wesley is very
uncomfortable looking at the position
it's just it's just ugly what happened
on the board but yeah here we have
kinked g5 budding Magnus just retreated
in 92 and it was in this position that
ding resigned the game as there is
nothing more to do here well king f5
seems to be the last move but I think he
just like put the King there while
resigning and then the board picked the
move up could be could be that and
Magnus was up on time for the entire
game at the end of the game dink had
like 20 seconds on the clock Magnus said
over 10 minutes so Magnus really
prepared this line and he knew very well
that it was ok to grab that pawn and I
don't know I will have to wait a bit
longer for someone else to try the
Marshall attack in such a you know it
elite event so now with this victory we
end the three days of the rapid section
and now I will show the standings for
those of you who are interested here are
the standings and Magnus wins the rapid
event and but we still have still have
two days of blitz where you can win
additional 18 points so anything can
still happen
so cross and in so lead with 15 out of
18 repeating his success from Abidjan
all wins and only 3 draws Nakamura
followed Falls in second place with 11
out of 18 and then we have a tie three
place tie Giri iron and Wesley so with 9
points then with eight we have Dingaan
and then how to Krishna nipper with
seven and with it with with six points
so far but we like I said it's a double
round robin next next two days so anyone
can still do wonders in this tournament
yeah III think I already mentioned I
believe Magnus's before performance here
is above 3000 not not really sure how
much exactly which is very nice and also
he is once again the the highest rated
rapid player in the world after after
this tournament so that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank Barak awesome who's in Parma now
Apogee me Holly Manchin was ever Aldo
Ally jr. and a wild McVicker for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous video thank you
for watching and I will see you soon
continue to check up on some other games
I've seen you suggested some games so
I'm gonna check them out from this very
nice rapid event check out on your other
suggestions and continue doing so until
we start our next big saga thank you all
I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your Sunday